find out how the life-science community
uses Google cloud platform to organize
the world's genomic information while
also making it securely accessible and
useful on this episode we'll see how
it's done through a quick demo where
you'll use Google's implementation of
the HTS get protocol and Sam tools to
create a project using public data to
you know makes us the study of the
genome and its environments today DNA
sequencing advances have made biology a
data rich field for the first time and
the volume of genomic data available is
growing exponentially cloud genomics
offers petabyte scale genomic data
processing and analysis now let's see
how this works to get started with this
lab you'll have to enable the genomics
API we run some commands in cloud shell
to run the HTS get server and attach it
to a local docker container network
named test we then use sequence
alignment map tools to view statistics
about a small range on chromosome 11 on
a public genome in just a few seconds
the Sam tools have processed over 1,500
reads that were streamed from a file in
Google Cloud storage highly complex
searches that previously could have
taken minutes are now taking as little
as four seconds this kind of speed and
scalability is accelerating
breakthroughs in understanding the
causes and subtypes of conditions in
ways that can advance diagnosis and
treatment as never before
quick labs is an online hands-on lab
library available 24 hours a day seven
days a week with more than 150 labs on
every cloud topic from intro to expert
level each lab helps you learn a new
skill in about 30 minutes using Google
Cloud take the Google genomics
QuickStart lab the same lab we just went
through today and practice working with
Google genomics API for yourself when
you're ready use this link to take the
lab and when you're ready to sign up for
GCP use this link to apply a three
hundred dollar credit to your account we
want to hear from you every week we'll
be answering a question from our viewers
so let us know what's on your mind in
the comments below
[Music]